[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here okay
i'm gonna have to oversimplify some
things in this video but i think it's
necessary to get my point across
so at this point in 2020 there are two
types of electric vehicles
there are teslas
and there's everything else
and i have messages for both and i'm one
of those people that honestly believes
that electric cars are the future of
cars
but they're just that
they're the future and so there's a lot
of work that both have to do to get
there also apparently apple is also
working on an electric car that could
launch sometime in the next couple of
years likely with some sort of high-end
battery tech sounds really interesting
sounds very expensive too
also are we sure it's going to come with
a charger but seriously jokes aside
let's say apple is working on an
electric car for the next somewhere in
the next decade they won't be alone a
lot of people a lot of companies a lot
of the biggest in the world are working
on electric cars to be at the forefront
of their innovations for the next little
bit so as someone who's been driving a
lot of electric cars and who lives with
one and all of its flaws and all of its
upside and feel strongly about the whole
thing
i've got a lot of messages so let's
start off with this
dear electric cars
if you're coming out today with a
premium electric car
with 200 miles of range
you're already behind so range is of
course super important and to me it's
the number one baseline indicator for
just how good the electric car program
is within a certain manufacturer it's
like a baseline metric
so today right now
the highest 10 electric cars are going
what 250 to 400 miles on a full battery
right so the king of the hill right now
is tesla's long-range model s that's a
100 kilowatt hour battery 402 miles and
that's right now
today in 2020 people are driving that
car right now so when someone comes out
and says we're gonna launch a new
electric car
sometime in the future maybe in a year
or two and it'll have
200 miles of range to some that number
sounds pretty good but to me when i hear
200 miles that's still pretty low that's
low enough that i still have to spend
mental energy thinking about remembering
where and when i'm going to charge this
thing think about this the median range
for a full tank of gas for a typical gas
car is about 400 miles today with the
best ones getting about 600 700 miles on
a full tank of gas
that is what you eventually want
electric cars to match maybe even do a
little bit better since there's less gas
stations so that's why you see tesla's
already announced plans for a truck
that'll do 500 plus miles next year and
then a triple motor model s that'll go
520 miles and a two-door roadster
that'll eventually do 620 miles when it
eventually comes out i'm guessing in
2022. all of that comes from years of r
d priority on battery tech
drive trains efficiency all the tech in
the cars arrow weight reduction all of
that stuff
to ultimately achieve the same level of
convenience as a gas car and speaking of
gas
dear electric cars
gas stations
are pretty underrated like the electric
car is only half the story the charging
network to charge these cars is the
other half of the story and it's
arguably just as important as the car
itself it's something we kind of take
for granted but the confidence of
being able to just run your car down to
nearly zero and just know that there is
going to be a gas station somewhere
within
a mile or two of you probably
is kind of amazing it's huge and so in
this world of electric cars that
obviously doesn't exist yet so it's
being built and uniquely it's being
built often by the car maker themself so
tesla building and owning their
supercharger network and actually
electrify america
is owned by volkswagen group and so
there's more popping up every day and so
my bold hot take is i think this part of
it needs to be a collaborative effort
and look i know that's a lot more
complicated than it sounds and i know
that's easier said than done
but think about this
at this very moment in time i find it
pretty much impossible to recommend an
electric car for daily use that is not a
tesla
if you plan on doing any road trips
and this is a mostly u.s perspective
that's because tesla's large and growing
supercharger network here is literally
as important to the car as the range or
the build quality or literally any other
feature honestly maybe even more so
matter of fact i've said this in the
past and i'll go ahead and say it on
record in this video again
if the porsche tai can
could use tesla superchargers
i would rather have that than a model s
to be honest just because of my set of
feature priorities obviously build
quality inside but the way the car
drives it's still a four-door with
plenty of space and the software is good
enough i don't use autopilot all that
much i would rather have a tie can if it
could supercharge
but it can't there was just a story
recently about a couple who got their
shiny new hundred thousand dollar
electric porsche went for a road trip
and it took them
nine hours to go 130 miles nine
hours basically it came down to them
having an unlucky streak of like a bunch
of chargers in a row they visited either
being out of service or slow or full
or or whatever like they couldn't see
that stuff on the map because there was
no guarantee you were just sort of going
where you thought you could find a good
one and they even passed some shiny new
tesla superchargers and couldn't use
them because the porsche is not
compatible
but imagine if it was
that would be in my opinion a game
changer for that car i could actually
recommend cars like that way more often
so literally because of road trips
remember road trips i eventually think
we'll get back to that but because i
need to go
to an ultimate tournament or go visit
family in another state i literally
cannot recommend or buy for myself any
electric car that's not a tesla because
the charging networks aren't quite there
yet for any of them so here's my
question
why aren't more electric cars
compatible with tesla's supercharging
network like it seems like a win
overall right it would be fast charging
available for your car in a bunch more
places makes it way easier to recommend
your car
what is there so maybe there's some sort
of licensing fees or some sort of hidden
terms that tesla's built in they said
they've made it available why hasn't
anyone taken them up on that i actually
tweeted this last week wondering why it
hadn't happened to which elon casually
responded that tesla superchargers are
being made available to other electric
cars but just the fact that this isn't
common yet
is fascinating to me i'm not saying make
your car dependent exclusively on
superchargers no no no no that's a bad
idea but just adding that compatibility
on top of the existing compatibilities
already wouldn't that be great but hey
this may never happen maybe this is like
me asking apple to add a usbc port
alongside the iphone's lightning port
just because hey it would make it
compatible with way more things it's
only a benefit to your product right
but they obviously have dreams of a
lightning ecosystem that's turned out
pretty well and i feel like in the car
world a lot of these manufacturers have
dreams of their own lightning their own
charging network their own secret sauce
which isn't built yet
but that's their dream but look if the
long-term goal is to match the
convenience of gas cars then you want to
eventually get the range all the way up
to match the gas cars and then build up
enough electric chargers to be as common
as gas cars now i can see the range
getting there eventually but to build up
all these chargers to match how many gas
stations we have is going to take a lot
and there's no way you do that all
yourself so you might as well make it
compatible with the ones that are
already the most built out
i'm just saying anyway okay so there's
an article on electric pretty recently
about someone at ford pretty high up
sort of throwing some shade at tesla
saying things like the doors fit
properly
about ford cars the plastics and other
materials color match the bumpers don't
fall off the roof doesn't come off when
you wash it
he's saying buyers will not have to make
these
compromises with ford's electric
vehicles but see what he's obviously
leaving out and what i see so often when
talking about the electric cars coming
from these other big manufacturers is
there is still a compromise it's not
that compromise but there is still a
compromise because the mustang machi
which i've driven and that i love and
that i think is great i think it's one
of the most user-friendly and reasonable
and well-thought-out electric cars to
come out so far that mock e the
entry-level model goes 210 miles on a
charge
and the fully max spec best version they
can possibly make 60 000
mach e
goes 300 miles on a full charge and by
the way of course none of them will do
supercharging with tesla's network
that is a compromise and so guess what
ford and many of the others
people have been choosing the tesla a
lot lately you might have noticed and so
that means you're right to use the word
compromise but people are often picking
the one with the great battery with the
performance and fun to drive stuff and
the tech features over the one that's
actually better built it's just facts
there's a lot of people like me out
there who would drive a super minimal
very plain car with not that many bells
and whistles if it went a thousand miles
on a charge over the best built thing
you could possibly make if it only goes
200 miles it's an exaggeration obviously
but still that's the priorities that a
lot of electric car buyers have right
now because there are no chargers
everywhere so for all those advantages
the big automakers have of being able to
mass produce quality cars at huge scale
with great materials awesome designs
tight tolerances and a ton of skus they
are still three or four years behind in
the battery and drivetrain technology
and the charger networks which are
enough for people to not really want to
leave the gas cars that they know and
love and it's the reason i don't drive a
thai can or a maki or an e-tron right
now and it's the reason that a tesla
feels like the only financially
responsible version of a premium
electric car as far as convenience goes
which brings me to tesla oh you probably
thought you were safe from this video
tesla but no i drive one which means i
have to deal with all the upside and all
the downside that comes with them and i
have some messages for you too dear
tesla
this one advantage that you have that's
very real that we've talked about is
eventually going to go away
right eventually tesla has gone all in
on their battery technology and their
drive trains and their efficiency and
their years ahead on that right so
they've been building their battery
their gigafactories they've been
building their electric motors and
slapping a car on top and that's almost
like the least important part of the car
itself because when you drive it it's so
fun and it goes so far and you can plug
it in so easily so a lot of people out
there buying their first electric car
getting a tesla that have never owned a
porsche or an audi or bmw or a ford
aren't really
super used to super high quality
interiors they're fine with the interior
of a tesla because it matches their
priorities and that's great but
eventually
there's the other half
of people who when they spend 50 70 90
000 on a car expect a certain level of
interior quality eventually tesla you're
gonna have to match and invest in
matching that quality of build and fit
and finish you know i've had a lot of
little random quirks with my model s
things like wind noise things like water
in the taillights of course there's that
one drivetrain failure i had years ago
and then that model y that i reviewed
here a little while ago this year has
some weird quirks some strange build
quality flaws in a review car but it's
not just about me lots of people have
had way more severe issues than me and
the rate of these issues with tesla is
still currently high enough that you
eventually got to address it now when is
that point when
should that focus shift
and that's hard to say you know
obviously tesla's doing super well right
now their investors are really happy
they continue to make big strides in
battery they're about to drop eventually
a roadster that'll do 0-60 in 1.9
seconds with 620 miles of range like
that take money to create and it's crazy
i'm looking forward to that car so much
but it's also kind of a shame that i
feel like i already know that that car
is going to have some
build quality shortcomings or at least
some quirks or some plastics or some
panel gaps as much as i hate saying it
just because that's what we expect from
every
new production line from that
californian car company at this point so
here's here's my take see this graph
here
this graph is a little old it's from
2016 but it still applies here it's
showing the minimum maximum and median
range of electric cars out plug-in
hybrids and gas cars so electric cars
are way lower than gas cars as you can
see but they bump up a little bit every
year as the technology improves in 2020
the max is around 400 so maybe in a few
years when the roadster finally drops
with the max around 600 and the median
is coming up with it because the tech
lowers in price i think when we
eventually get to the point where the
median range for an electric car
at a certain price
matches the median range of a gas car
for the same price
that's when i would love to see tesla
take a little more investing in fit and
finish and hit that last whack-a-mole of
just build quality just just finally
focus on build quality like you
obviously still continue to invest in
battery technology and drive trains and
all the stuff that makes tesla tesla but
yeah eventually the others are going to
start to catch up in that department and
you're going to want to catch up in the
department you're lacking in which would
hopefully put everyone on the same
playing field in both respects so there
you have it now there's a lot of other
things i could rant about in the
electric car world from the naming
schemes of these things to the software
updates that they should all definitely
get to all the grills that they can
definitely slowly get rid of to these
weird door handles they all feel the
need to do there's a lot happening in
electric cars but the bottom line is
electric cars
are coming and they're coming fast and
they all if they're gonna make it they
ought to all get better together in all
the ways where they struggle
that's basically it hope this helps
that's how i feel about it let me know
in the comments below if you're into the
idea of this electric future and do you
think your next car
will be electric
or not i think that's a fun question
either way
that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace